Я почну з представлення наших
доповідачів, перш за все, я хотів би
дати їм можливість сказати
пару слів про себе, щоб
представитися перший
міжнародний національний
експерт ЄС для школи координувати
експерт
експерт координатор
пару слів про себе
так, вітаю всіх, я дуже
радий бачити багато знайомих облич, ми
працюємо разом протягом багатьох
років, це дуже добре, що ми
маємо якийсь стійкий процес
із багатьма
зацікавленими сторонами та дуже захопленими людьми,
які хотіли б змінити веб-систему
України на краще і вітати
всіх, сподіваюся, що у нас буде дуже хороша
[Музика]
від Національного навчального центру
Міжнародний навчальний центр ви можете
багато розповісти про
себе,
тож спробуйте спочатку
вітати колеги мікрофони дуже
хороші все добре щодо
Ринок
[Музика]
Я б сказав, що я мав великий
досвід роботи з
системою, я дійсно усвідомлюю
необхідність синергії між
навчальними закладами та роботодавцем, ми
навчаємо наших студентів саме для працівників, з яких ми працюємо.
мають дорослих людей, які
потребують перенавчання, і
це
спеціалісти світових установ, які
знають, як навчити їх належним чином відповідно до
потреб ринку праці, насправді
слово «освіта» насправді є чудовим
ресурсом для роботодавців отримати
висококваліфікований
персонал, завдяки  ви дякуєте наступній
Федерації роботодавців, яка брала участь у
багатьох заходах, і він міг поділитися
своїм досвідом такої співпраці
кілька нас із вас, перш за все
щодо проекту ЄС для навичок,
я б сказав, що це була дуже хороша
співпраця
в  Німецька інституція
та ми співпрацювали
таким чином у роботі
промислових підприємств із ветеринаром через
подвійну освіту та навчання. Я кажу,
що ми досягли дуже хороших результатів
і результатів, і вони дуже позитивні,
також хочу сказати, що в
роботі
рівень співпраці між
працівники та Департамент
освіти, а через них і
червоні освітні коледжі та вищі
навчальні заклади є дуже
ефективним і ефективним, ми підписали
меморандум про співпрацю, і це ці
скарби, які ми накопичили
під час
обговорення спільної діяльності, я хотів би сказати  що у нас є
кілька аспектів наших
дискусій, традиційно ми будемо
говорити про
освіту, а також про навчання та
навчання дорослих, насправді це навчання протягом усього життя. По-друге, у
нас є різні
форми освіти та навчання, які
дійсно специфічні для ринку праці,
це не лише формальна освіта,
вони були  останнім
часом досить успішно розвиваються, а деякі з них
навіть домінують, наприклад, у
сфері ІТ формальна освіта не є
пріоритетом,
інші форми, але в будь-якому випадку ми всі живемо
в Україні, і ми добре усвідомлюємо
академічну зміну ситуації,
і вона різко змінюється і
Перше, про що я хотів би попросити всіх наших
доповідачів цього вечора
просто дати
оцінку цій ситуації
та оцінити можливості
поточного ліжка, яке
воно здатне відповісти на
виклики, з якими стикається наша країна та суспільство,
хто міг, хто міг  Почніть, будь ласка,
з вас,
насправді, у мене є
досить багато ідей, які я хотів би
спростити для них,
тому ви згадали про нові зміни, нові
виклики, безперечно, вони у нас є,
але
хто вони насправді,
їх небагато, ми
досліджували
працю  на ринку досить багато років,
і ми багато років співпрацюємо з веб-
системами,
ми повинні розуміти, що наша війна
почалася не
в 2022 році, а зараз ми говоримо
про повномасштабне вторгнення в Україну,
але насправді виклик цього вони
вже
існували в  ця система, включаючи
демографічні економічні виклики,
виклики, викликані війною, включаючи
збільшення кількості психологічних і
фізичних
травм, люди, яким довелося втратити,
хто втратив свій дім і змушений
переїхати, насправді ми
мали ці виклики раніше, але
насправді це повномасштабна інновація  просто
примножив процеси та прискорив їх
до того, як на міграцію було витрачено більшість
рядків, але зараз це великі
річки, тому насправді
велика проблема полягає в тому, щоб просто фізично
погодитися збільшити
чи вони різко збільшилися,
на жаль, однак
ситуація продемонструвала більшість
українських систем, включаючи це  система
виявилася достатньо стійкою,
щоб розширити
весь цей виклик,
і тепер настав час для дуже швидких
і, сподіваюся, успішних
кроків, якщо ви подивитеся на різні
ланцюги та компоненти української
системи освіти, ветеринарна освіта є
найбільш закритою, здебільшого близькою до
реальності та  звичайно, ми хотіли б
досягти найвищої можливої ​​ефективності
та результативності щоразу, у будь-який
час, коли я можу спостерігати. Я спостерігаю за
цією системою з
2005 року. Я можу сказати, що напрямок
дійсно абсолютно правильний, звичайно, ми
цінуємо підтримку  наші партнери
іноді
багато речей, дещо залежить від
політиків, але довгострокова тенденція,
на мій погляд, позитивна,
серйозно, першим є зменшення
кількості студентів у системі, і
ми повинні визначити нові цільові
групи та зосередитися на них,
дякую  дякую, колеги,
я думаю, що у вас
точно
виникнуть запитання, поки ми під час
нашої дискусії про особистість,
мій колега, який
збиратиме запитання, щоб підготувати їх,
повернеться до чинної системи, яка
включає погані установи та
національні навчальні
центри під керівництвом  Національна
служба зайнятості, як ви могли б, як ви могли б
оцінити ефективність Ефективність
це 5 або 12, якщо це
12-класова система,
добре, це забагато,
але дозвольте мені не оцінювати в оцінках
національна служба зайнятості на цьому етапі –
це процес зміни нашого формату
співпраці з роботодавцями, яку
ми почали з великих працівників,
які справді
потребують
збільшення свого
персоналу, і їм
потрібні нові підходи,
наша система, яка система освіти
достатньо гнучка, і ми реагуємо на
виклики на ринку праці,
і я вже багато разів згадував,
що вони
роботодавцю
потрібні кваліфіковані працівники,
і він хотів, щоб їх навчили за
короткий час,
але його дружина
перепідготовка дорослих полягає в тому, що
пріоритет для
навчальних центрів наразі пробуджується над
людьми, які люблять забиратися далеко, які
не втрачають
це їхня робота  в особливому регіоні, тому
їм довелося переїхати до регіону,
де їхня кваліфікація не користується
попитом, і вони готові пройти
перенавчання, і вони готові отримати
професійну професію.
Для мене це було трохи здивовано,
ми бачимо, що багато людей з
університетом  освіта
вони готові пройти перекваліфікацію, але вони
не готові навчатися досить
довго, тому що будь-який роботодавець, який
хоче отримати
кваліфікованого працівника, він хотів би взяти
його сюди сьогодні,
але в іншому випадку
він каже, що я не знаю, що ми  і де
буде моя компанія завтра, чи через
тиждень, чи через півроку, тож ми маємо
з повагою реагувати на систему перепідготовки, тож
запроваджуємо короткострокові курси, дякую, дякую,
міс Джулі,
ми маємо внесок від першого
нашого першого експерта  Пан Геннадій хоче
зосередитися на
ширших цільових
групах через демографічні
причини, у нас також є ваша ідея
змінити колишніх, і тепер ми хотіли б
почути від роботодавців
можливості співпраці з
веб-системою,
можливо, якісь негативні та успішні
позитивні моменти, дякую, пане, я
хотів би сказати кілька слів про нашу
співпрацю зі світськими, якщо можна,
так, але так, я буду
коротким, тому, коли ця проектно-органічна
організація
увійшла в регіон відділення, ми не були
готові, і ми
співпрацювали з нашими так
з нашими ветеринарними закладами, як ми
це робили раніше,
22 лютого. Повномасштабна інновація
почалася, і,
на жаль, понад 75 відсотків
територій паризького регіону
були окуповані,
а завдяки
молодим людям із південної частини
регіону та східної частини
регіону, який
вони привезли, вони приїхали,
відділення прийняло їх, і ми
разом з нашими колегами з загального профілю
розпочали
короткі курси для перепідготовки цих молодих
людей і за фінансової підтримки
наших німецьких
партнерів, тому ми перекваліфікували
деякі професії
або
спеціалістів з електрики, а
також іншу
сферу  Ви можете знати, що наші
вчителі повинні проходити
перепідготовку кожні три роки через
таємницю та війну. Перепідготовка
була відкладена, і нам вдалося
перепідготовити
їх за допомогою наших головних
партнерів,
вони щойно витратили 550
000 українських зелених на
навчання.  діяльність
і знати про співпрацю між
роботодавцями та ветеринарними школами, чесно кажучи,
ми не будемо
оцінювати
це
в балах,
але гнучкості недостатньо,
якщо, наприклад, мені потрібні троє
спеціалістів з деяких у певній
професії,
але
це  робиться в
основному на робочому місці,
тому я хотів би попросити
учасника нашої панелі, щоб ми повинні
розглянути зміни в умовах ліцензування,
інакше ми б не робили жодних кроків
вперед, це вже
30 років, про які ми просто
говоримо  зміни в системі ліцензування,
але, на жаль, жодних кроків вперед
і пару слів про
кваліфікаційні центри, це справді
дуже хороша робота, і це справді дуже потрібна
робота, але будучи колишнім та
нинішнім працівником,
я б сказав наступне
в закладі, якщо це ліцензія
для такої професії, чому цей навчальний
заклад має бути
переоцінений і реалізований як
кваліфікаційний центр, тому ми повинні
змінити систему
в цілому, я б сказав, що ми є
роботодавцями та вільними закладами, тому ми
взаємопов’язані, ми співпрацюємо
і ми будемо співпрацювати  у майбутньому,
дякую, щиро дякую, пане Валері,
з точки зору
величезних потенційних територій і того, як побудувати
ці мости між різними сферами
інтересів
між
бізнесом,
який не зосереджує
увагу на освіті, та ветеринарними установами,
які зосереджені на
Досить часто ви
спостерігаєте ситуацію, коли компанії
або знають
достатню мотивацію, але не мають ресурсів,
або якщо існує потреба в дуже невеликій
кількості
дуже вузьких спеціалістів,
система um не може впоратися з цією
проблемою, і зараз ми  намагаючись
розвивати інформальну та неформальну
освіту та навчання, і ми намагаємося
продемонструвати
та
надати доступ ширшим групам
населення до цієї нової форми
навчання, тому я хотів би, щоб
він брав участь у
ряді дослідників, які
навички  і професії користуються найбільшим
попитом, і яка
невідповідність
з точки зору того, що потрібно роботодавцям і що
пропонує ринок праці,
отже, є ряд невідповідностей, якщо
ви не йдете в конкретні професії,
тому що їх дуже багато
ми можемо побачити більше заходів у технічних
аспектах або оподатковуваній професії,
наприклад, якщо ми візьмемо, наприклад, зварювальника
[Музика]
більш-менш успішно у нас є
шлях до роботодавців і
колишніх студентів, і відгуки були
позитивними, немає великих  невідповідність тут,
звичайно, є блок професії
в поганій професії, який має зникнути,
але це інше питання
[Музика] [
Музика]
іноземний
працювати в команді знати деякі іноземні
мови,
і це не робить цього, тому цей
компонент не  взагалі існують у навчальних програмах,
і вчителі дуже часто не можуть
навчати, тому вони не вважають це
потрібним. На це є різні причини,
але цього
насправді не вистачає, але з деякими
підприємницькими навичками ці речі
також відсутні в нашій освіті
традиційно орієнтована людина, щоб почати
працювати на когось, як на заводі, як на
фабриці, людина просто приходить і працює
там,
і ніхто не думає про самозайнятість
цієї людини чи просто про
можливість відкриття невеликого
підприємства, і це насправді недолік
основні прогалини,
які, на нашу думку, не дуже, але
це дані, які
схвалюють, і це лише загальні
тенденції,
тому підсумовування технічних навичок є нормальним
залежно від професії, але на
середньому рівні все добре, але
навички спілкування та підприємливість
навички це не нормально, ці речі
відсутні, дуже дякую, я думаю, наші
викладачі зможуть відповісти на
ці коментарі, я хотів би
запитати Валері, що це дає, що
це таке, коли ми говоримо
з позиції роботодавців  або
навички, які забезпечуються
справді збігаються з
вимогами [музики] um, із попитом
ринку,
або дійсно існує потреба у
вдосконаленні чи вдосконаленні
навичок спілкування тощо, я хотів би відповісти
на наступне  До речі,
якщо ми говоримо про дуальну освіту,
це згладить і ці проблеми, і це
дійсно може вирішити цю проблему, але
що стосується цієї дуальної освіти, то
в Німеччині інші підходи,
і тут вони різні,
як вони приймають студентів
у компанії Палати  Комерція,
а також школа,
тож наша
школа — це все,
тому наша школа має прийняти
учнів, має розподілити учнів,
але коли ці речі зроблені,
ми перевірили цю інформацію про дуальну
освіту, усі ці комунікаційні та
інші навички, е-е, удосконалилися в процесі
здобуття геоосвіти, і ми можемо
сказати, що це навички
стають кращими,
а учні отримують кращі м’які навички, якщо
вони працюють, якщо вони
навчаються на основі роботи, і ця модель
дуальної освіти має певні
особливості, але я вважаю, що викладачі,
на жаль,
ми  мають обмежені можливості
реально охарактеризувати досвід
Міністерства освіти у
сфері набуття підприємницьких навичок,
але я хотів би запитати Лілію
про присутність
цього елементу, пов’язаного з м’якими
навичками, у навчальних програмах і як
цей
центр зайнятості є  це те, що
потрібно, це те, на що
є попит, чи, можливо, ви бачите якісь інші
прогалини, якщо ми говоримо про тенденції
ринку праці, і тоді ми спробуємо
створити ці мости чи можливі моделі
комунікації, дійсно державний
центр зайнятості має  11 ветеринарних шкіл,
і лише вісім із цих центрів
зараз справді працюють через
військові дії.
Деякі з цих шкіл, деякі з цих
центрів не можна використовувати для освітніх
цілей, але я можу сказати вам про
освітні програми, які відповідають потребам
Підприємства, усі наші вісім шкіл, наші
центри допомоги, у
нас є базовий курс з
організації
підприємницької діяльності, також
бізнес-планування, а також генерування
бізнес-ідей, і вони дійсно дуже
популярні, цей курс, тому що є
деякі державні програми,
центр зайнятості спільно з
міністерством  економіки, і вони
впроваджують, їм надають мікрогранти
громадянам України, які дійсно
хочуть отримати ці гранти, е-е,
вони також допомагають у бізнес-плануванні,
тому що
є деякі основні законодавчі вимоги
щодо того, що вам потрібно зробити, щоб розпочати своє
підприємство, і це  курси дуже
популярні, і люди навіть можуть подавати свої
заявки в Інтернеті,
ми хочемо пройти курс з цього, щоб
тема всі курси доступна
на веб-сайті державної
служби зайнятості, що стосується навичок м’яких відносин,
я можу сказати вам наступні дійсно
роботодавці ми  у вас є багато зустрічей
з ними, і роботодавці тепер думають,
що
найважливіше для роботодавців це те,
що людина повинна бути відповідальною,
не завжди потрібно, просто ця
людина має прагнути вчитися,
працівники готові перенавчати людей,
які працюють, але це  людина має бути
підготовлена, має бути готова пройти перенавчання, у
нас є багато вразливих груп
людей, і ми намагаємося охопити їх у
різних аспектах,
але виходячи з того, що кажуть роботодавці,
уразливі групи людей не
завжди хочуть працевлаштуватися, вони не хочуть
хочуть перекваліфікуватися вони
недостатньо відповідальні, щоб піклуватися про своє
подальше працевлаштування
Я думаю, що загальна ситуація зрозуміла,
і я думаю, що викладачі, які
сьогодні тут, ви також можете поставити свої запитання або
додати свій коментар Телебачення почне отримувати ваші
запитання, тому я  хотів би заохотити
вас поставити більше запитань,
я б дозволив
відповісти на це запитання, але ви можете
поставити будь-які запитання, і ми спробуємо
їх обробити. Титан збере ваші
запитання. У
мене є два запитання. Я отримав два
запитання. Я прочитаю їх, щоб  ви
розумієте, що ви
сказали, що ветеринарна тенденція правильна,
що таке тенденція і які її
риси тенденція тенденція
загальна тенденція
полягає в кращому розумінні ситуації
краще розумінні ви знаєте,
що це дуже загальна відповідь, але я
спробую пояснити вам, у мене є  честь і
досвід роботи з ветеринарним дослідженням у
2005 році, і якщо ми,
незважаючи на всі негативні моменти
цієї
тенденції, ми бачимо, що система
децентралізована, це перевага,
рішення подав рівень лояльності, і саме
тут вони повинні бути прийняті в другу чергу,
і є  краще розуміння
їхніх недоліків система
розуміє, де є проблеми,
де є недоліки,
і
загалом система розуміє, як
їх можна
покращити чи змінити у 2005 році не було
розуміння, що систему слід
змінити, була ця ідея, що
радянська система ветеринарної медицини  є найкращим, і
наразі немає точок зростання, ми розуміємо, що
потрібні зміни, також є деякі
кроки
для внесення певних змін, ми можемо сказати, що
все прямо зараз, але
визнаємо, що проблема існує, ми
виявили деякі проблеми в
конкретних галузях  в управлінні у
фінансуванні в підготовці вчителів
під час стажування, тому ми виявляємо
та звужуємо ці проблеми, ми вивчаємо
ці проблеми та пропонуємо різні
механізми вирішення цих проблем,
можливо, не завжди це рішення, тому цей
механізм є успішним через
суб’єктивні та об’єктивні причини.
не тільки слово, але є
базова здатність системи справлятися
зі змінами, і є деякі генетичні
проблеми, і
ця радянська економіка сприяла зростанню
цих генетичних проблем, і для
вирішення цих проблем нам потрібні дуже
великі ресурси та політична воля.  нам
потрібно більше часу, хоча ми не маємо
стільки часу, але ми повинні розуміти, що
ми працюємо з обмеженою кількістю
інституцій і людей, які
успадкували від радянської системи, і
цих людей також потрібно змінити,
їм потрібно трохи часу, щоб  бути
змінено, і ми не можемо дійсно пришвидшити
процес, тому, на мій погляд, тенденція правильна,
якщо є якісь екзистенційні проблеми,
які потрібно змінити, це стосується
залучення нових людей у ​​цю систему. Я
маю на увазі не лише школи, а й
систему ветеринарної медицини  загалом
і в цій системі багато чого робиться,
і нам також потрібно змінити
структуру фінансування,
якщо є якісь рішення, якісь
рішення вони обговорювалися,
якщо вони будуть прийняті, то вони
будуть прийняті, це те, що ми не
знаємо  але це те, що ми побачимо
в майбутньому, і друге запитання,
це Інститут професійної
кваліфікації, хто є автором цього
запитання, друге запитання
навчання м’яких навичок є завданням
цієї системи, моя коротка відповідь: так,
хоче додати щось тут
іноземне
ми не чуємо, тому що доповідач
не використовує мікрофон,
тому це те, що слід
робити на рівні сім’ї. Я знаю, що таке
тайм-менеджмент,
але, можливо, це не завдання ветеринара –
вивчати навички спілкування, чи, можливо, не тільки цю
систему  має навчити вас цьому,
і по-друге, якщо
система освіти справді
працює, тоді її слід стандартизувати, а
деяких учителів потрібно навчити, а
якщо говорити про
систему освіти в цілому, це слід вивчати
в школі, а потім продовжувати в цьому
круто і далі  в університеті,
це інвестиція в
систему освіти в розвиток людських активів, якщо
це стандарт, це має бути
уніфікований
стандарт, і управління часом має
викладатися так само в жетомері в цирку чи
будь-якому іншому регіоні України,
будь ласка, сідайте на свої місця,
тому що наш  колеги, які стежать за вами
в Інтернеті, вони вас не бачать. Я маю
на увазі, що
незабаром я подумаю про те, що
сказав Radiance, так, я згоден, що це завдання для
всіх рівнів освіти та тест для
цієї стандартизації, яку я викликав. У мене
є колега, і ми маємо  ця
філософська дискусія з ним про
стандарти та подібні речі,
ви знаєте, стандарти – це добре, але я
думаю, що
нам подобається в нашій системі освіти,
я не говорю лише про те, що
нашій системі освіти
не вистачає свободи системи, я не пам’ятаю  хто сказав, що я
цитую
когось, кого ви знаєте в цій середньовічній
Італії, це були Борхеси, там було
багато повстанців, добре, незабаром
у Швейцарії
все було дуже мирно та спокійно
в середньовіччі, але швейцарці
дали їй щось нове, тому  Я думаю, що
Свобода принесе нам кращі результати.
Дякую за цю
живу дискусію. Я знаю, що роботодавець
каже взяти активну участь у цій
дискусії, тому що я хочу поставити це
запитання нашим
учасникам.
Я хотів би поговорити про
співпрацю
підприємств і шкіл.
це тристороння угода, ми раніше
казали, що це величезний тягар, а
сьогодні нам дійсно потрібна
тристороння угода, але люди
її бояться, і коли учень бачить, що є
повідомлення про тристоронню
угоду між школою  Підприємство
намагається розглянути це питання,
але на заході тристоронні угоди
мають певний сенс, і вони дійсно
ефективні, якщо я як роботодавець інвестував
час і гроші, щоб навчатися цьому
столяру, а потім після закінчення навчання
студент не несе відповідальності, тому що
це  Карпентер зараз вільний.
Наші працівники
дуже вдячні за ваучери, це
добре, але від
імені роботодавців операції
45 15 близько 35-10 це було справді
ідеально,
якщо ми зараз говоримо про дуже
конкретні речі коди даних  доступу,
дякую, колеги, я хотів би
нагадати вам, що ви можете поставити запитання
та справді орієнтувати цю дискусію, у нас
не так багато часу, але я
хотів би поставити запитання
кожному з вас про наше
майбутнє, наприклад, як нам потрібно  змінити, щоб
відновити, щоб відновити, щоб відновити
Україну,
ми маємо чудовий досвід до
2014 року, потім від 2014 до 2022, і koviti
справді допоміг нам вирішити багато проблем,
він допомагає нам із цифровізацією, але нам
не вистачає інших речей,
тому ви як  експерти, як би ви
запропонували, як би ви запропонували нашу веб-
систему змінити на перебудову, щоб
реконструювати нашу країну,
тож я даю вам три дивіться, я можу сказати, щоб
подумати над вашою відповіддю, щоб поміркувати над
цим питанням, хоча я розумію,
що це в глобальному рівнянні,
тож що  Я хочу сказати, що ми обговорювали, що
сьогодні головне полягає в тому, що ви
повинні стати ще більш гнучкими, ніж
це стало протягом останнього
другого року, у будь-якому випадку, дійсно
було багато опитувань і
опитувань, і я, президент, сказав фокус-
групам з  роботодавці іноді
навіть дивляться з мого рівня. Мене
здивували роботодавці,
особливо якщо говорити про сільське господарство та
сільське господарство, е-е, ветеринарні школи не
завжди достатньо добре обладнані, щоб підготувати
експертів, яких потребує роботодавець, якщо нам потрібно
бути більш гнучкими в цих підходах і
формах  Освіта так, подвійна освіта
подвійне навчання він здатний
Я ненавиджу адаптувати людей до
умов праці, а також дистанційна робота [
Музика]
дозволила нам покращити
навчальні здібності
[Музика],
а також
це
Система освіти та навчання не повинна
втрачати
членів команди
але реформи, щоб
утримати цих людей у
системі та покращити систему, оскільки якщо
ви втратите
людський капітал, ми не зможемо
покращити саму систему. Так, я згоден,
але я хотів би зазначити, що якщо ми
розглядаємо дизайн інвестиційного проекту,
Я впевнений, що національний бюджет
включатиме принаймні 30 відсотків для
праці, задіяної у відновленні
країни, і яка це
реакція
роботодавців на додаток до нинішнього
підвищення голосових ваучерів
так  саме українська армія
окуповує та звільняє
українські окуповані території,
території
дійсно
знищені, і ми повинні бути готові
відновити
цю частину нашої країни, і як ми маємо це
зробити,
ми маємо використовувати комплексний та
сукупний
гнучкий підхід та спрощений
підхід  щодо перепідготовки та
перенавчання робітничих професій, тож ви
думаєте, що формат буде
створений за допомогою практичної
реалізації так, що ми повинні він має
підготувати нас, щоб бути готовими
до цього так, але ми знаємо, що важкий час
породжує сильні проекти,
і я хотів би  щоб надати національного
експерта, щоб узагальнити,
як потрібно розглядати відновлення,
ви використовуєте vet,
тому питання досить складне,
насправді
я
думаю,
що ця система,
щоб бути здатною належним чином
відповісти на виклик, потребує
кількох речей, як кажуть механіки
Найкраща деталь у механізмі полягає в тому, що її
немає в механізмі, тому що він
ніколи не ламається, тому
ми повинні проаналізувати та оптимізувати
систему багатства, а також
стати не тільки
більш гнучкою, але й
дрейфувати у відповіді на
виклики.
ми не повинні боятися
власних помилок,
але вихователі бояться
помилок навіть більше, ніж інші люди,
тому що наша система в значній мірі
зосереджена на уникненні помилок, тому що
з раннього шкільного віку
наших дітей навчають  почати з
цього конкретного
конкретного місця на лінії, і
ми використовуємо певний колір або наскрізь, і
ми повинні бути більш різноманітними, а
також наша система повинна стати
більш людською популістською, ми повинні
звертатися до різних груп різних
клієнтів, тому що ми всі усвідомлюємо, що
десятки  тут вони зосереджені, чисельність населення
становила
ох 100 000 людей, роздуті 200 000
людей,
тому ми можемо побачити очевидну тенденцію, тож це
просто це
не означає, що кількість
людей, які хотіли б отримати
ці професії, зменшилася, вони
просто використовують різні способи  отримання
ліків і навчання, тому ми повинні бути
більш винахідливими
у пошуку наших звичаїв, на жаль,
ми отримаємо багато людей
з
психологічними травмами або фізично
недієздатними, які ми повинні мати, ми повинні
знайти підхід до них,
це справді виклик  ці речі
досить філософські,
зрештою вони призводять до практичних
підходів, якщо ви розумієте основні
принципи, вам буде легше
знайти практичні підходи.
обговорення дуже актуально,
дуже відповідає концепції ЄС щодо навичок, яку
ми зараз завершуємо,
ми намагалися розробити різні
форми навчання,
включаючи навчання без відриву від роботи, дуальну
освіту,
залучаючи
ці заклади до
отримання
кваліфікацій,
ми також зосередилися на підтримці
вчителів і
Розширте їх можливості та зробіть їх здатними
працювати з різними
цільовими групами та в іншому
середовищі, у нас є початкова
освіта,
і якщо для якої цільової групи переважно
молоді люди, але в той же час зростає
попит на
повну кваліфікацію,
ось чому що  освіта повинна
пропонувати збалансоване портфоліо освітніх послуг
ми зіткнемося з багатьма проблемами
ми матимемо виклик людей, які
повернуться в Україну, які зараз
перебувають в інших країнах, з точки зору того,
що люди, які отримали кваліфікацію,
іноді дуже пристойну кваліфікацію
під час перебування за кордоном для  цього року
чи двох ми маємо створити
для них таке середовище, щоб вони могли
опинитися на українському ринку,
де як FED освіта має
реагувати на таких людей, я маю на увазі
центри кваліфікації та
служби зайнятості, як ми маємо
синхронізуватися з
директивою ЄС щодо  визнання
професійних кваліфікацій,
тому що ми маємо синхронізовані
освітні стандарти, але як щодо
професій?
довгий перелік питань, які потрібно вирішувати
керівнику, але важкий час створив дуже хорошу
комуністичну професійну спільноту, і наші
викладачі
демонструють справді успіх та
ефективність, тому що справа не лише в
навчанні  або освіта, але мова йде про
роботу з людьми,
і
вранці ми на нашій дискусійній
панелі ми сказали, що ми
лише
на початку довгого шляху
до Джонні,
і я хотів би вітати всіх вас
взяти
участь у процесі, це не
про  деяким
інституціям
нам потрібні не лише
меморандуми та угоди, а й
багато, іноді чотири, п’ять-шість наказів,
щоб ми встигали з порядком денним,
я хотів би додати
вас, хто створив цю дуже цінну,
дуже цінну
спроможність, яка б розвивала
іноземні
через  забезпечення якості
освіти протягом наступної
години ми будемо говорити про
контакт, який
генерує, вони називають це забезпечує
якість освіти,
а також про інструменти, які можуть бути
використані для забезпечення якості,
і з нами є почесні спікери,
тож нехай  Представляю
керівника Інституту дерев’яних професій
Національної академії педагогічних
наук України Наталію
Керівницю проектів Міністр освіти
і науки Наталію
Директора міжрегіонального але того
освіти
модельного мистецтва моделювання та дизайну живе
професійно-освітній центр
Заступник директора
та
ін. Заст.
принцип
печери,
перш ніж ми розпочнемо
нашу дискусію, дозвольте мені нагадати вам, що
наприкінці нашої дискусії ви
зможете поставити запитання нашим
спікерам як присутнім тут
фізично, так і тим, хто приєднався до нашої
дискусії онлайн,
тому, якщо у вас виникнуть запитання онлайн,
ставте їх  чат, і ми спробуємо
відповісти на всі ваші запитання, пов’язані з
нашою темою, тож давайте почнемо
з усіх викликів, з
якими ми стикаємося в освітній системі,
це освіта та підготовка кваліфікованих
працівників, а також економіка, для якої бізнес
вимагає
достатньої якості
забезпечення якості є одним із питань,
які зараз
дуже актуально обговорюються.
Багато людей запитують,
що таке якість у цій сфері, і ми
спробуємо знайти відповіді на ці запитання
разом зі спікерами, але ми
також будемо
більш практично зосереджені
та спробуємо  визначити
інструменти,
які,
на нашу думку та на думку наших
доповідачів,
забезпечують якість професійної
освіти та навчання та як цього можна
досягти,
звичайно, цей
іноземний
навички період реалізації проекту
забезпечення якості, перш за все,
залежить від
ключових трьох  компоненти зміст
Освіта та підготовка
компетенції вчителя педагогічна
методологія викладання, а також
матеріальна база обладнання для
навчання,
тому якщо ми не бачимо контакту,
це завжди фокус
реформування
системи, говорячи про якість, ми маємо на увазі
стандарти як освітні стандарти, так і
професійні стандарти
та відповідно  до таємниці
освіти і науки у нас є
151 національний стандарт, якщо розроблено в
Національному кваліфікаційному агентстві,
яке каже, що вже написано
276 сім професійних стандартів є
в Україні
хм [
Музика]
що у вас є великий досвід у
розробці освітніх та
освітніх стандартів
тож, на вашу думку,
це освітній стандарт, який
базується на компетенціях, основний
інструмент, який міг би забезпечити
рівність освіти, і яка
необхідність у таких стандартах, і,
можливо, в чому їх особливість, чи, з
іншого боку, які проблеми
з цими професійними стандартами,
дякую за ваші запитання, скажіть, я хотів би
привітати учасників нашої
секції, і я хотів би сказати, що
питання рівності в освіті, я б
сказав, дуже активне з самого початку
нашої конференції, звичайно,
я так, якість  освіта є дуже
актуальним твором, тому що вона
характеризує нашу спільноту в цілому,
вона характеризує розвиток
спільноти та, враховуючи
виклики, з якими сьогодні стикається наша країна,
наша спільнота, наше суспільство має
реагувати на ці
нестандартні
умови, нам потрібно навчати це  робочої
сили для відбудови нашої
країни та загалом якість — це
покращення
системного рівня,
ми не можемо сказати, що якість може бути
системною річчю, це динамічний процес,
який потребує постійного вдосконалення, поки
інші умови культурні економічні
політичні вони впливають на це  якість,
якщо ми використовуємо цей компетентнісний
підхід у розробці
професійних стандартів, а також наших
освітніх стандартів і навчальних програм,
цей компетентнісний підхід
визнано базовим підходом у Європі,
який міг би забезпечити якість
освіти,
увесь цей технологічний аспект
аспектів цифровізації, і ми досить
успішні в цьому, тому що
ми використовуємо цей підхід, заснований на компетенціях,
скоріше
деякий час, і коли ми говоримо про
цю описову декомпозицію
компетенцій на знання та навички
та компетенції на основі європейської
рамки кваліфікацій, що також
добре, це
хороша основа для розвитку
якості та планування
змісту освіти, друга річ, якщо
ви говорите про інструменти, які
дозволять нам забезпечити якість, це
питання до педагогіки, а також до
нашої академічної академії, у нас є деякі
політичні та економічні
проблеми управління  та інструменти та один із інструментів,
який дозволяє об’єднати
економічний та управлінський аспект, це
професійний стандарт, оскільки, скажімо,
професійний стандарт, вони можуть
дозволити нам планувати зміст на основі
вимог економіки та
ринку праці, і тому ці стандарти мають
певну еволюцію  і ми можемо бачити, як
професійні професійні стандарти
коли-небудь еволюціонували
з точки зору професії до цих
нових стандартів, і ми знаємо, як ці нові
професійні стандарти виглядають, як
освітній статус мають подібну
еволюцію вони були розроблені з використанням
певної методології протягом певного періоду
часу, а потім методології  було змінено,
і тепер освітні стандарти мають
відповідати лише професійному стандарту, якщо
він доступний,
тож так, справді є переваги та
є деякі проблеми, також якщо цей
процес потрібно більш інтегрувати,
має бути Синергія, і якщо є
професійний стандарт, тоді  нам потрібен
освітній стандарт негайно, якщо
є освітній стандарт, нам потрібно
негайно розробити навчальний план,
тому, якщо є запит від імені
особистості, усі ці стандарти мають
бути гнучкими та їх потрібно змінити, щоб
відповідати вимогам  особистість
десь для дуже конкретних
рекомендацій щодо стандартів, я,
ймовірно, поділюся своїми ідеями в
кінці нашої дискусії,
гаразд, дякую
іноземний
професійний стандарт, навчальний план
і оцінювання є ключовими компонентами
під стандартом, ми маємо на увазі професійний
стандарт, але зараз  ми працюємо в
системі освітнього стандарту і,
як ви сказали, є еволюція, але
рухаючись вперед
і рухаючись відповідно до європейських
стандартів, ми розуміємо,
що
нам потрібно працювати над навчальними програмами,
і тому що навчальні програми
повинні бути якісними документами, тому що від
цього залежить зміст і результат
нашого навчання буде залежати, і як частина
цього проекту,
якщо ми протягом тривалого часу працювали над нашими
власними навчальними програмами, і це те, що вірш
сказав нашій головній панелі, і тепер потік
йде до Наталії Преценко,
щоб говорити про розробку
навчальних програм про Юдею  впровадження в
системі ветеринарної медицини, це перше питання,
і я також хотів би, щоб ви поговорили про
ці навчальні програми та побачили, чи можуть вони
сприяти тенденції, яка є в
Україні.
Я маю на увазі навчання впродовж життя, будь ласка,
дорогі колеги,
мені приємно приєднатися до цієї
професійної спільноти
та  Я хотів би
відповісти на запитання: нам потрібно
розробити навчальну програму, тому що у нас є
деякі стандарти, ви пам’ятаєте, що у нас
не було освітніх стандартів, у нас
були лише професійні стандарти. Мені
всім сподобалося, ми працювали в п’яти
регіонах і ми розробили 20
кваліфікацій  добре чи погано, і їх потрібно
покращити, можливо, у них є певні
недоліки, але процес почався, і ми
почали процес розробки цих
програм, цієї навчальної програми, коли я
працював над цим питанням, я проаналізував
багато книг,
академічної літератури, я ставив це
запитання, що таке  ми грали, ми
весь час грали в якісь ігри, ми
приходимо з новими ідеями, нам потрібно вміти
дуже простими словами пояснити, в
чому різниця між
програмами, які ми мали раніше, і
навчальним планом, який ми маємо зараз, я думаю, нам бракує
певного розуміння
освітня програма –
це процес, коли присвоюється певна кваліфікація,
наприклад, у нас є повна
середня кваліфікація, як молодший
бакалавр і так далі,
яка різниця між навчальними програмами
зараз вони орієнтувалися на результат,
коли ми працювали з навчальними програмами, ми
були орієнтовані на процес  нам потрібно розпочати
цей професійно-освітній процес, ми
читали цю навчальну програму,
іноді
вчитель матеріалів чи
електрообладнання вони могли погоджуватися зі своїми
колегами, тож не погоджуватися, але це був
процес, який ми зараз орієнтуємо на результат. Ці
два основні компоненти – це час і вартість
часу та  гроші,
через це нам потрібно оптимізувати
багато речей, і ця нова навчальна програма
орієнтована на результат, і це також є
основою цього професійного стандарту, у нас
не було стандартів, і ми
вирішили зробити освітню програму
на основі
якогось освітнього стандарту.  не хочу
зашкодити нікому, ви знаєте, що вам потрібен
рік на розробку, щоб затвердити, ніж отримати
ліцензію, а потім усі ці програми, які
грецькими потребують схвалення, потрібен
час, і це можна зробити, але ми використали
цей модульний підхід, який  це не нова
річ, ми працюємо в системі ветеринарної медицини
десятки років, і ми
знаємо, що цей модельний підхід було
започатковано ще в 2000 році, і деякі
люди намагалися над цим попрацювати, але в
модулі
є щось завершене, це
не  частина часу це не перший
семестр чи другий семестр або
фрагмент першого сезону, це
блок цієї програми цього навчального плану,
який також є орієнтованим результатом і чимось,
що ви можете використовувати на ринку праці, і
якщо ви можете створити ці модулі,
ми будемо  мати ресурс, тому що ми
могли б розробити мікрокваліфікації.
Я бачу тут пана Юрія, це дуже добре
включено сюди, коли є
мікрокваліфікація, коли є деяка часткова
кваліфікація, коли є повна
кваліфікація,
але
які проблеми,
які проблеми я маю  особисто
ми стикаємося з тим, що навчальні програми мають бути
гнучкими, але якщо ви говорите про
північний регіон літа чи південний
регіон мікроживої,
навчальні програми будуть різними, коли нам
потрібно навчати деяких з кухарями, це
називається, це звідси є  багато
риби, тут багато м’яса, тому,
розробляючи цю навчальну програму, нам потрібно
і можемо це врахувати, але це
вимагає часу, нам потрібно навчити людей
створювати такі програми та
навчальні плани, але вони зможуть
це зробити,  почнуть робити це там, де вони
розумітимуть, що їм потрібен клієнт,
якщо вони мають гарну навчальну програму, яка
користується великим попитом, і клієнти
захочуть навчатися за цією навчальною програмою, і
нам потрібно якось стабілізувати цей результат
за кордоном,
тому ми кажемо, що людина вийшла
ми хочемо, щоб
студенти, які закінчили цю навчальну
програму, були корисними
на ринку праці,
тому нам потрібно подумати про
цю кваліфікацію.  повна
кваліфікація або часткова кваліфікація,
тож якщо ви говорите про навчальні програми, я
завершую побудову навчальної програми
в Excel. Я хочу, щоб кожен аркуш паперу
містив певні вказівки,
тому, я думаю, ми продовжимо серію
вебінарів
і тестування цієї короткої навчальної програми, і
це  результат цього довшого
навчального плану
Наталія,
ви стверджуєте, що такого роду програми
насправді не можуть забезпечити гнучкість
цієї траєкторії,
нам потрібно орієнтуватися, чи існує якась
робота, якась технологія чи якісь конкретні
умови виробництва, як-от певне
обладнання, це можливо розробити
типу навчальних програм і, можливо, моя конструкція
зможе вам допомогти, гаразд, дякую,
і продовжуйте нашу співпрацю, і в
цьому контексті
я хотів би запитати, чи
Практичний випадок вашого закладу
Наталія
може підтвердити, що ця тенденція працює
Я'  Я скажу, що Леві є піонером у
розробці та впровадженні цих
короткострокових курсів,
які дозволяють працівникам
швидше вийти на ринок праці,
ми були першими, хто підготував найбільшу
кількість студентів, які говорять на цих
короткострокових курсах,
що було добре та було добре  але привіт
колеги, дякую вам за це запрошення
і дякую за цю можливість
поділитися своїм досвідом
минулий рік був дуже важливим для нас,
тому що наш заклад, ви
знаєте, ми сказали, що у нас є багато
курсів перепідготовки
для дорослих,
але в березні минулого року
було  ідея, яку ми
реалізували з цим навчальним центром
за підтримки ООН. Ідея полягала в тому,
щоб
представити кілька короткотермінових курсів для внутрішньо переміщених осіб,
і місія цих курсів цього
навчання полягала в тому, щоб ресоціалізувати
жінок, перш за все,  Вибачте
за цю гендерну нерівність, тому що до нас
приходило багато дівчат, які
жили в гуртожитках наших шкіл,
тому ми хотіли залучити їх до цього
короткострокового тренінгу, які були
труднощі,
емоційна адаптація була важкою
справою, тому що коли  ми запропонували цю ідею,
вони не зовсім розуміли, навіщо їм
потрібні перші студенти, якщо ви
вісім жінок, а пізніше протягом
цих кількох місяців з березня по серпень ми
навчили 88 жінок, вони пройшли наші
короткострокові курси,
ми розробили навчальний план
і  76 72 тижні протягом трьох тижнів
із отриманням деяких часткових
кваліфікацій, дякую,
цей вид навчання
підтримується певними навчальними
матеріалами з оціночними матеріалами,
щоб ми могли оцінити та
пізніше
дозволити цим працівникам вийти на ринок праці,
наскільки я знаю  вам вдалося працевлаштувати
всіх цих жінок, яким
вони нам допомогли, і вони були активними в
розробці цієї навчальної програми,
і завдяки їхній ініціативі
компетенції зберігають ваші визначені знання,
які ви повинні отримати, щоб
наші студенти могли адаптуватися до
умов праці на цих підприємствах, я думаю
це один із критеріїв якості
наших послуг, а також ця якість
також залежить від веб-
умов, які створюються у ветеринарних
школах та ветеринарних закладах,
і
враховуючи виклики, які
ми маємо сьогодні, я маю на увазі пандемію та
роботу
Навчальний процес включає в себе як
онлайн-технології, так і деякі офлайн-
технології та деякі гібридні тренінги,
і я вважаю, що
ця цифровізація
дуже глибока в нашому освітньому процесі, і
нам потрібно лише рухатися вперед,
і нам потрібно навчати це, тому що
якість також залежить від професійних
рівень наших викладачів
у рамках реалізації цього
проекту ми приділили багато часу цьому
[музиці]
і тому, як ця цифрова технологія була
впроваджена, як вони навчали ветеринарних
шкіл, як ми працюємо з цією технологією, це
питання, яке я хочу адресувати
Ірині Смірновій
Будь ласка, слово за вами, що ви можете
сказати про цю
[музику]
технології вітчизняні іноземні
іноземні
шкільні вчителі,
і
з часом це стало дуже популярним серед
загальноосвітніх шкіл середніх шкіл
досить вищих і вищих навчальних закладів
не тільки в нашому регіоні
ми почали з
боротьби з
викладанням
надання  навчаючи навикам ІТ під час
офлайн-офлайн-сеансів, ми не думали
про онлайн-сесії,
тому ми розробили, щоб тестувати, ми
навчаємо їх, як робити презентації,
як використовувати інтерактивні столи,
а також ми розробили електронні
матеріали, які полегшили
їхні навички
з цими  студентів
у 2022 році ситуація змінилася перша
пандемія
військової російської агресії,
і в нашому регіоні вони були фактично
бойові дії як у наших регіонах і
регіонах помірного клімату, так і в
освітніх установах
до змушених впроваджувати
дистанційне
[музичне]
навчання та онлайн-методики
та ці
підходи стають популярними серед вчителів,
ми почали фактично розвивати
сферу розвитку компетенцій
це
також у рекламних матеріалах
з причиною розробки логотип
шкіл IET Computing, які ми рекламуємо
можливості
в нашій школі, які є різними веб-сайтами,
зрештою, у нас є вчителі  з
різних регіонів,
будь ласка, стикайтеся з будь-якими труднощами будь-які
проблеми з впровадженням цифрових
технологій викладання Технології
впровадження цих технологій
визнають
навчальні заклади, тому що ми
надаємо їм нашу підтримку, наприклад,
Challenge, і ми допомагаємо їм розгорнути
робочий простір для фізичного виховання, а також
навчити їхніх вчителів  і як використовувати
онлайн-курси з ІКТ, які
говорять про це,
проблема полягає не в натхненні чи
пошуку нових ресурсів, як їх
слід використовувати,
тому ми фактично беремо участь у
міжнародних програмах Міжнародні
проекти,
наприклад ЄС для навичок, ми
брали участь у багатьох тренінгах
курси, і ми зрозуміли, як
слід
систематично впроваджувати освітні технології, коли
все було розпочато ще в 2010 році
кожен учитель використовував інструменти, які
він чи вона
знала, як ними користуватися, наразі ми маємо
доступ до
спеціальних просторів, таких як робочий простір Google
Office 360, модель наших навчальних
закладів  розгорнули їх за
підтримки
навчально-методичного центру і вони
ними активно користуються. Я хотів би
підкреслити, що це чудово, це
дуже сприяє підвищенню
якості освіти. Ви хочете
щось змінити, так, я хочу сказати, що міс.
Ірина була дуже активна під час тренінгу,
проведеного представником Фіджі,
коли він так він, він насправді поділився
своїм досвідом, як вони супроводжують їх
Впроваджують
навчальні інструменти, і коли він побачив,
які платформи та які ресурси
використовують наші вчителі, наші тренери,
вона була справді здивована.
хотів запитати міс Ірину, у вас
багато платформ, де
можна успішно використовувати цифрові ресурси,
яка платформа є
найбільш
відповідальною для наших шкіл і
скільки часу потрібно, щоб навчитися
користуватися цією платформою,
яка з них найбільше  Я кажу, що це
найпростіший, щоб навчитися працювати
з ним, це стосується
системи дистанційного навчання. Я хочу сказати, що цей
робочий простір Google,
доступний для наших викладачів, має
приватний обліковий запис Gmail, і в разі
переходу на іншу платформу це не
буде  дуже болісно
з точки зору часу, який
здебільшого залежить від часу
розгортання цієї системи в
навчальних
закладах, тому в середньому це приблизно
один місяць або принаймні два тижні, добре, так,
дуже дякую, це також
політичне  Технологічні
показники або результати якості – це
тестування проекту
[Музика]
надано серію тренінгів
Навчання в Азії є
досить складним завданням не лише для студентів,
але й
для вчителя.
Моє запитання:
поділіться, будь ласка, своїм досвідом
участі в такому разі,
дякую,
що  ви взяли з цих тренінгів
і як ці результати вплинули на
якість тренінгів доброго дня,
і через ЄС для навичок я брав участь
у тренінгу в грудні з тестування
знань
тренінги
зібрали близько 40. OLX
використовувати їх на практиці
тренінги було справді викликом  тому що
це було в цьому гм,
але в будь-якому випадку ми повинні були робити наші домашні завдання, у
нас було
багато сесій, і всі інструменти
були розглянуті належним чином,
незважаючи на те, що всі слухачі
були досвідченими вчителями,
проблема з нами отримала багато
комерційних
станцій,
ми  ми згадали
кваліфікацію Essentials і
вдосконалення кваліфікації,
і ми повинні розробити
цю
систему оцінювання, щоб визначити рівень
знань і навичок особи, яка
буде
під час навчання ми розробили
теоретичні тести, а також розвинути
Суспільство
не дуже складно,
що включало три  рівні
вона цього хоче двійники три
оцінювальна
таксономія, яка
включала три рівні P1 P2 і P3
Вибачте, що перериваю,
перш ніж перервати вас, оскільки ми
дуже обмежені в часі, але чи могли б ви розповісти
нам, як ці інструменти
можуть вплинути на якість навчання,
я вважаю
що
співробітники повинні займатися
розробкою інструментів,
тому що, говорячи про практичний
іспит, практичні завдання
повинні бути розроблені таким чином, щоб
підтвердити його особисту
кваліфікацію, тому
співробітники повинні бути
залучені до
розробки інструментів тестування
інструментів дякую дякую дуже
пам’ятайте
кваліфікаційних центрів
і ми розуміємо, що все більше і більше
офіційних і неформальних
іноземних
[Музика]
33.
тому я б запросив його Валентину
поділитися досвідом
не створення цього центру,
а ефективної роботи
центру
доброго дня, шановні колеги,
перш за все хотів би сказати  що наш
навчальний
заклад займається навчанням
кухарів
протягом 30 років,
тож я думаю, що для нас не було проблемою
створити кваліфікаційний центр, щоб отримати
акредитацію в національному
центрі акредитації за
двома професіями
в грудні 2022 року наша
ветеринарна школа отримала кваліфікацію як
кваліфікаційний центр
ми
ввели
тестовий іспит тестування
для всіх людей,
які пройшли свою кваліфікацію,
які люди можуть звернутися до нас, щоб підтвердити
свою кваліфікацію та отримати офіційний
документ,
вони теж
багато в своїй кар’єрі, і вони також
підвищують свою впевненість у собі, яку
вони отримають  офіційні документи,
визнані цією державою
з 2022 року, сьогодні
переходять до їх кваліфікації лише минулого
тижня двоє осіб через
кваліфікацію та цитує
сертифікати
людей віком від 30 до 30 років.
Отже, мова йде про людей, які
почали здобувати освіту
[Музика],
але в якийсь час вони
допомагали  їм
потрібен кваліфікований персонал, тож
дякую вам
у Good Times
швидко,
ми пообіцяли, і
так, у нас є кілька запитань,
і я хотів би поставити одне запитання,
будь-хто з вас може відповісти
якість освіти залежить від синергії
освітніх установ і  вплинути на
розробку професійних стандартів
і викладання навчальних
тренінгів
[Музика]
це буде основою для підготовки
кваліфікованих спеціалістів, але питання полягає в тому, що б
спонукало
бізнес, суспільство та найкращі
школи оновлювати зміст
освіти та навчання за кордоном
[Музика]
ми обговорювали м’які навички, і
одна з них – це
відповідальність наших студентів, ми говорили
про відповідальність, коли йдеться
про трудові функції, мотивація – це
щось внутрішнє, і кожен громадянин
України,
я думаю, у
нас є дуже очевидні мотиватори, це
кризові мотиватори, насправді кожен
відповідальний
громадянин
також повинен відповідально відповідально ставитися до
вирішення різних питань, і якщо ми говоримо
про розвиток економіки у
війну та період першої світової війни, то слід
пам'ятати, що кожен з нас повинен мати
внутрішню мотивацію до якоїсь діяльності, а
також до оновлення свого професійного
стандарту  а також оновлення наших
навчальних програм, якщо говорити про наші
мотиватори, я б зосередився на цих трьох
завданнях, і ми дуже вдячні тим
людям,
які надають донорську підтримку нашій країні,
це міжнародні проекти, які
мають дуже чітку програму та
завдання,
і
вони  дозволяють нам вирішити ці податки в рамках
певного проекту, тож я вважаю, що
ми створюємо розробку професійних
стандартів, освітніх стандартів і
навчальних програм, що є хорошим початком і хорошим
результатом,
тож це цикл із великою
кількістю документів, починаючи з
професійних стандартів освітніх
стандартів  кваліфікаційне речення
затвердження кваліфікації ми можемо обговорити
це питання пізніше, тому міжнародні
проекти
добре служать хорошою основою для
звуження регіональних проектів прямо зараз
проектна діяльність може бути організована в
регіонах,
і цей вид проектної діяльності з
найбільш стандартним розвитком повинен
мати  об’єднати робочу групу, і ці
люди могли б працювати як за професійним,
так і за хорошим освітнім стандартом, а також за
певним фінансовим мотиватором, і це має
великий вплив на кожну людину, оскільки будь-
яка робота потребує оплати, і
це залежатиме від роботодавця, а
також від  керівництво кожної
конкретної школи, і це, безперечно,
принесе певні хороші результати, і коли ми
мотивуємо людину до певної діяльності, ми
можемо бути впевнені, що ця людина
також буде підготовлена ​​до інших видів діяльності,
які також є свого роду інвестиціями в
людські активи, тому що
іноді  наші люди працюють без цієї
фінансової мотивації, а також існує
самомотивація, яка нам
потрібна, щоб піти у зовнішній світ,
тобто просування освіти
просування доступних продуктів, що є
своєчасною відповіддю на певний професійний
стандарт, коли професійний стандарт
обговорюється, проходить через деякі слухання
коли це буде
обговорено, це може бути робоча група,
яка буде працювати над освітнім
стандартом чи навчальним планом, а ті
люди, які розробляють професійні
стандарти, мають бути залучені до
розробки інших документів,
і тоді кожна людина буде відповідальною
та мотивованою відбудовувати нашу країну,
щоб  Я слухаю, щоб бути
мотивованим для наших викладачів і
тих, хто розробив професійний
стандарт та/
або деякі освітні стандарти, і,
скажімо, їм присвоєно певне вчене
звання, як-от доктор філософії,
добре, коли вам потрібно розробити стандарт,
вам потрібно  вивчити стільки ресурсів і
документів про літературу,
яка схожа на окремий продукт,
авторське право,
так, це те, що нам потрібно змінити,
добре, дякую, чи є ще якісь
думки з цього приводу,
можливо, є якісь інші запитання до
наших доповідачів,
можуть бути деякі зауваження,
добре, дякую  багато, на
жаль,
тому, на жаль, є деякі люди, на
жаль, це не так, на щастя,
люди в Інтернеті слухають RC,
на жаль, у нас немає інших
питань, тому сьогодні під час цієї дуже
короткої зустрічі нам вдалося проаналізувати
деякі досягнення в контексті
забезпечення якості,
а також  у контексті нашого
проекту ви за навички та B ми
акцентували увагу на компонентах, які
дійсно можуть забезпечити якість
професійної освіти та навчання, тож
дорогі друзі, дякую вам за вашу активну
участь, ми рухаємося вперед, щоб
рухатися вперед до нашої Перемоги все
найкраще для вас, і я хотів би нагадати
вам,
що
ми все ще будемо мати
це останнє слово у фойє, ми
матимемо деяке неофіційне спілкування, тому
побачимося пізніше, до побачення